on sera tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo comme
chaque vendredi nous faisons un point
sur l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
au sommaire de cette édition la france
en huitièmes de finale les bleues ont
décroché leur qualification face au
pérou un match évident les entreprises
de saint quentin en yvelines elles se
sont organisées pour permettre aux
employés de vivre et derrière les bleus
reportage à suivre dans cet hebdo nous
recevons sa carrière dit il est
vice-président du medef des yvelines
présidence de l'organisation patronale
loi pacte reprise économique vu des
yvelines nous en parlerons avec lui
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons sur la fusion des communes
de rocquencourt et du chéné puis sur le
conseil municipal mouvementé de
coignières à quelques jours des soldes
d'été les commerçants du sud canal ont
animé le centre commercial de montigny
le bretonneux
outre les dégustations et démonstrations
de produits les visiteurs ont eu droit à
la visite d'acrobates
quant aux enfants ils ont pu s'amuser
sur une structure gonflable un événement
destiné à faire connaître davantage les
commerces aux habitants propos
recueillis par grégory canale et toki
nirhy lanto on l'avait déjà fait sur le
mois d'octobre donc en plus petite
échelle
et puis on avait vu que ça avait très
bien marché les clients étaient vraiment
au rendez vous et on a décidé sur le
mois de juin dont faire une plus grosse
donc avec vraiment de l'animation du
spectacle on a fait faire des flyers on
a vraiment mis au courant ne clientèle
s'est pas spécialement pour vendre c'est
vraiment pour se faire connaître comme
jouet club qui est complètement de
l'autre côté ça leur permet de venir à
nous est de faire découvrir aux gens qui
sont pas spécialement au courant qui a
un jouet club
est-ce qu'on passe en a on le voit pas
et ben là ils vont le découvrir voilà
donc c'est pour vraiment les autres
commerçants aussi qu'ils sont pas
spécialement sur la place et si le beau
temps était au rendez vous durant ces
animations il sera aussi présent durant
tout le week end pour la journée de
samedi météo france prévoit du soleil
pour l'ensemble des communes de saint
quentin en yvelines
les températures dépasseront les 20
degrés il fera par exemple 21° à voisins
et montigny le bretonneux 22 à elancourt
maurepas et guyancourt mêmes prévisions
pour dimanche
un avant-goût des conditions météo de la
semaine prochaine les maximales
atteindront les 25 degrés avec un
ensoleillement qui pourrait durer toute
la semaine
la température a grimpé dans les coeurs
des français jeudi soir l'équipe de
france a décroché son ticket pour les
huitièmes de finale face au pérou score
final 1 0
mais ce n'est pas toujours évident de
suivre les aventures des bleus au
travail certaines entreprises comme
sodexo à guyancourt se sont organisés
pour que leurs salariés puissent suivre
l'événement aurélie rond s'est glissé
parmi eux assisté à la victoire de
l'équipe de france face au pérou alors
que l'on est censé se trouver derrière
son bureau une réalité chez le groupe
sodexo basé à guyancourt l'opérateur de
restauration et de services accueille
900 salariés
ce mondial 2018 est un moyen de
rassembler encore plus son personnel
l'organisation en tout cas de des matchs
en tout cas de la diffusion des matchs
pour la coupe du monde ça rentre
pleinement dans le cadre de ce fameux là
ce qu'on a envie d'offrir à nos
collaborateurs sur site pour pour leur
qualité de vie en plus de la
retransmission des matches des bleus sur
écran géant la salle de restauration a
été décorée aux couleurs du drapeau
tricolore
une urne a été mise à disposition pour
que chacun puisse parier avant le
lancement du match un moment que
n'aurait pas manqué martin laetitia et
sylvie c'est super puis ça permet de se
retrouver sur un moment convivial donc
c'est vrai que ça génial ça nous permet
de nous voir dans un autre cadre de la
future agréable et puis c'est la face du
monde qu'on soutient la descente pour
fois
c'est ce qu'il faut une plage de travail
assez flexible donc c'est vrai que vu
leur c'était quand même facile à
s'organiser
selon une étude menée par le site
internet bureaux locaux en france 36 %
des entreprises ont décidé de diffuser
certains matchs dans les espaces communs
19 % des entreprises autorisent leurs
salariés regarder les matchs
discrètement al'inverse un quart des
entreprises ont décidé d'interdire à
leurs salariés de regarder les matchs au
bureau
de toute façon tout le monde a envie de
regarder le match ça arrive une fois
tous les quatre ans et c'est plutôt un
événement qui est très fédérateur qui
est conviviale donc enfin voilà on s'est
dit autant l'organiser de manière
officielle pour pour faut pour tout le
monde et pour que les gens voient là
puissent le voir en toute tranquillité
les salariés de sodexo vont encore avoir
de nouvelles occasions de partager ces
moments de convivialité puisque les
hommes de didier deschamps sont
qualifiés pour les huitièmes de finale
sur notre plateau zakaria redis nous a
rejoint bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes chef
d'entreprise alors est ce que vous vous
autorisez vos salariés à suivre les
rencontres de cette coupe du monde va
écouter quand l'équipe de france joue
tout le monde est intéressé et tout le
monde est passionné donc même nous chefs
d'entreprise on aime on souhaite
regarder le match donc on on le regarde
avec nos collaborateurs
quand c'est possible bien sûr les postes
par exemple d'administratifs c'est
possible un poste de production ça n'est
pas possible
donc voilà donc à chaque fois que c'est
possible on le fait on le permet alors à
côté de votre activité d'entrepreneur
vous est aussi vice-président du medef
des yvelines vous avez tenu hier soir
l'assemblée générale à chatou l'occasion
de faire le bilan de l'année 2010 est
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
au meeddat yvelines durant cette année
2010 est quels sont les temps forts
ah bah écoutez il s'est passé beaucoup
de choses
le medef bien sûr nahd et féline a
grandi parce que il a abordé une leçon
nombre d'adhérents donc sont des
entreprises et des entrepreneurs mais
surtout l'année 2010 est s'est
caractérisée par la désignation de
des conseils de prud'hommes en janvier
donc 2018 il ya eu la nomination des
soixante treize conseillers prud hommes
désignés par le medef et pour
effectivement servir dans les dents les
conseils prud'hommes de mantes-la-jolie
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye versailles
et et rambouillet leur propre peut-être
mon rôle c'est juger les affaires les
plaintes de le contentieux entre les
salariés et les employeurs et donc c'est
un moment où nous essayons d'être juste
de défendre de ne pas défendre
l'indéfendable et de défendre
effectivement la justice quand il s'agit
de deux problèmes de contentieux sociaux
au niveau national le medef va aussi
tenir son assemblée générale ce sera le
3 juillet prochain
c'est à ce moment là que vous allez
élire un nouveau président qui va
succéder à pierre gattaz deux candidats
sont en lice geoffroy leroux jeu froid
ou de béziers fondateur du groupe note
us technologies une société engagée dans
le digital et alexandre saubot directeur
général de l'aude groupe spécialisé dans
la construction de matériels d'élévation
votre sentiment sur cette élection
écoutez d'abord je salue la décision de
pierre gattaz qui a décidé de faire un
mandat ne pas multiplier les mandats
parce que il faut se renouveler
il est vrai que cette occasion pour le
medef yvelines
est une chose très importante alors bien
sûr
lors du dernier conseil d'administration
et lors de l'assemblée générale d'hier
nous avons choisi notre candidat le
candidat pour qui
nous allons voter et que nous allons
soutenir et je pense sincèrement
aujourd'hui je ne trahirai pas un secret
en vous disant que nous avons nous
allons soutenir geoffroy roux de bézieux
dans sa dans sa démarche pour être
président du medef national
pourquoi ce choix bah écoute et le medef
evelyne souhaite l'ancrage du medef
national dans les territoires pourquoi
parce que l'action du medef auprès des
entrepreneurs se fait dans les
territoires nous avons analysé les idées
la composition des équipes j'allais dire
des différentes écuries en lice en lice
pardon et nous avons constaté que nous
avons jugé que je frotte bézieux d'abord
sa démarche ses idées puis surtout les
membres de son équipe
c'est des gens qui sont issus des médias
des medef territoriaux quel est le rôle
du président du medef
on le voit souvent aux côtés du
gouvernement négocier avec les autres
partenaires sociaux que ce soit
l'assurance chômage
quel est son rôle en fait écouter le
président du medef doit être une devrait
être le porte parole des entrepreneurs
et des entreprises dans notre pays ils
doivent porter aux connaissances du
gouvernement les difficultés que nous
rencontrons
il doit également être force de
proposition parce que nous avons
beaucoup de choses à proposer au
gouvernement
et justement le gouvernement a présenté
le projet de loi pacte c'est à dire le
plan d'action pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises c'était
ce lundi 18 juin il prévoit notamment de
simplifier certains seuils de permettre
la création d'entreprises à travers une
plateforme en ligne ou encore de
faciliter les accords d'intéressement en
faveur des salariés
ces mesures est ce qu'elles vont dans le
bon sens écoutez pour nous toutes les
mesures qui visent à faciliter la vie
des chefs d'entreprise sont de bonnes
mesures
toutes les autres toutes les décisions
toutes les mesures qui visent à
améliorer la compétitivité des
entreprises
nous nous applaudissons et effectivement
nous les soutenons les mesures pacte les
la réforme pacte si vous voulez c'est
une réforme très complexe qui comptent
qui compte et que comporte beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'éléments nous
n'avons pas le temps d'en parler de les
détailler
mais les mesures phares sont
effectivement les socios de 10,1 à 250
salariés donc en passant par le celui 10
20 à 50
vous avez également le financement des
entreprises réorienter les parts des
français vers les entreprises vous avez
également l'objet social des entreprises
mais sur cet aspect des choses n'oblige
de l'objet social des entreprises
nous avons quelques réserves parce que
rendre l'entreprise responsable
de l'intérêt social et environnemental
peut ouvrir un champ je dirais que nous
ne maîtrisons pas de contentieux avec
les syndicats il était intéressant le
social par les autres syndicats je pense
à la cgt de prendre l'encontre de
l'intérêt social c'est important
évidemment l'intérêt social dont les
entreprises c'est l'intérêt de salariés
parce que sans nos salariés nous ne
pouvons pas faire progresser
l'entreprise ne pouvons pas créer de
richesses et de croissance donc
l'intérêt que nous portons d'un salarié
au contraire il est très important
ce que nous voulons dire tout simplement
c'est que il ne faut pas que ça devienne
un handicap pour l'entreprise que ça ne
devienne pas un handicap qui va venir
freiner la croissance et la création de
valeur
vous avez été sollicité par les député
des yvelines pour co-construire en
quelque sorte ce texte est ce que vous
retrouver certaines propositions que
vous avez pu émettre durant ses
rencontres avec les députés
absolument vous savez le rencontrons
assez régulièrement les députés les élus
de nos circonscriptions
nous avons évoqué à plusieurs reprises
ces fameux seuil qui sont un véritable
frein à l'emploi et à l' embauche par
exemple le seuil des 50 salariés tout de
suite vous êtes impacté par différentes
mesures que ce soit comme si une
entreprise que ce soit des dépenses
liées à l'information et c'était 1 tera
et puis surtout ces seuils parfois quand
l'entreprise est à 48 49 salariés et
pour répondre à une commande on est
obligé d'embaucher 10 15 salariés
temporairement pour répondre à cette
commande est derrière le seuil
redescendre 7,50 donc donné dire que
toutes les obligations liées au seuil ne
s'applique qu'après cinq années
consécutives de dépassement je trouve
que c'est une bonne mesure
parce que ça permet aux entreprises de
respirer de d'agir
de répondre aux besoins de leurs clients
sans être obligé si vous voulez de
immédiatement être soumises à ces à ses
obligations qui sont un peu pénalisante
parfois pour le pour le pour les pme
l'objectif affiché par le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire c'est de
relancer je cite je le relance et notre
croissance et notre économie
vous y croyez à écouter j'espère
j'espère que c'est l'objectif qu'il
poursuit en tout cas nous dans nos
échanges avec le gouvernement les idées
sont claires la transparence et les
draps et nôtres je dirais objectif à
tous est effectivement de déverrouiller
un petit peu le système économique pour
qu'on puisse aller chercher cette
croissance qui nous manque tant
je vous pose cette question parce que
l'insee cette semaine à publier des
prévisions de croissance
1.7 1,7 pour cent pardon pour l'année
2018 elle atteignait 2,3 pour cent en
2010 est ya quand même un ralentissement
de l'activité
comment vous l'expliquez écouter la
croissance a été effectivement impacté
par deux facteurs le premier facteur
c'est
l'investissement des entreprises qui a
stagné et puis le deuxième facteur c'est
l'affaissement je dirais de la
consommation des ménages l'affaissement
de la consommation des ménages a été un
peu impacté par les par quelques mesures
fiscales notamment l'augmentation d'un
siège et épais également l'augmentation
des prix du carburant
ce sont deux éléments qui ont un impact
est un peu le pouvoir d'achat des
français
l'investissement des entreprises a
stagné parce qu'il y à quelques
incertitudes qui planent si vous voulez
un peu sur le monde de l'économie
d'une manière générale c'est
effectivement le l'augmentation du
populisme en europe notamment l'italie
et qui viennent remettre en cause
certains équilibres financiers notamment
au niveau de l'europe
et puis aussi quelques quelques
tiraillements je dirai au niveau
international la décision de des états
unis de pénaliser les entreprises qui
vont commercer à notamment vite lire en
rond je dirais la visibilité de l'avenir
un peu incertaine et ça engendre
quelques craintes
ça fera la dernière question de
certaines entreprises le ressentent dans
les yvelines
tous les phénomènes que vous venez
d'évoquer oui évidemment on vous savez
dont les yvelines nous avons au label
d'entreprise airbus industrie et vous
savez qu airbus industries perd je
dirais la fameuse commande que l'iran
lui a passé donc si vous voulez
lorsqu'on discute avec les responsables
du site des yvelines
ils sont un petit peu je dirais pas
inquiets mais ils sont déçus désolé et
puis déstabiliser dans leur démarche
puisque c'est un très gros contrat qui
se voit disparaître parce qu'un pays a
décidé d'imposer sa vision au reste du
monde
voilà donc et aussi si vous voulez une
connaissant quelques petites pme
notamment une pme every man has qui
exportent de la confiture de grande
qualité aux états unis s'aperçoit que
parfois un petit peu aux états unis on
est en train de réagir en disant voilà
les européens viennent prendre notre
argent etc
donc c'est il ya quelques difficultés
quelques frottements qui ce qui ce qui
se crée par ci par là pour nous autres
entreprises qui exportent sa carrière
nîmes
merci d'être
sur notre plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes président du medef des yvelines
vice-président pardon du medef des
yvelines bon week-end à vous merci et on
passe maintenant en résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
la fin du service autolib en ile de
france le comité du syndicat autolib
métropole a voté ce jeudi 21 juin
la résiliation du contrat avec le groupe
bolloré l'entreprise en charge du
service d'auto partage de voitures
électriques une décision votée par la
centaine d'élus des 98 communes
adhérentes à ce dispositif en cause le
groupe bolloré exiger des collectivités
le remboursement du déficit d'autolib
une somme dépassant les 230 millions
d'euros
écoutez à ce propos le maire du chesnay
philippe brillault il a participé ce
jeudi au comité la veille d'intervenir
chez nos confrères de france bleu depuis
plus d'un an je vais à tous les comités
parce que j'avais déjà dénoncé le risque
effectivement de dérive
rien n'a été fait et je pense que c'est
vrai que ce syndicat qui a dû héberger
aussi en catastrophe il ya un an vélib a
mobilisé un personnel que je suis
exceptionnel et voilà tout cela en fait
n'est absolument pas gérer et nous avons
une décision brutale comme
malheureusement beaucoup de ses
décisions par rapport à des souhaits de
paris tout est brutale or en fait ce
sont des choses que l'on accompagne
alors c'est pas uniquement la ville du
channel soyons clairs je suis une des 98
communes et nous sommes conscients
depuis quelques semaines que on est pris
on est pris en otage
ce projet est en préparation depuis
plusieurs semaines la fusion entre le
chesnais et rocancourt a franchi une
nouvelle étape ce lundi 18 juin lors du
conseil municipal les élus des deux
communes ont voté la première étape de
la création d'une commune nouvelle
notamment le nom de la ville qui sera le
chesnay rocancourt un reportage de
michael l'hydro le chez nero concours
vont bientôt former une seule et même
commune les deux conseils municipaux ont
voté ce lundi 18 juin le principe de
faisabilité d'une fusion
cette nouvelle ville regroupera sous le
nom le chez nero concours trente deux
mille habitants début janvier 2019 avec
un seul maire à sa tête
nous nous avons travaillé depuis le mois
de septembre
régulièrement
pour apprécier le bien fondé de cette
nouvelle commune et quand nous avons
fait nos deux colonnes le pour et le
contre et bien en vue qu'au mois de mars
le colonnes pour était quasiment rempli
dans la colonne des pour selon les élus
cette mesure permettrait à rocquencourt
de bénéficier des structures et des
services de la ville du chesnay dans le
sens inverse les chaînés bien pour eux
de réaliser des économies en réduisant
notamment les indemnités sur le manque
de logements sociaux c'est
l'optimisation des dépenses qui est
importante même s'il y a effectivement
dotation globale de fonctionnement qui
est bonifié et même si effectivement sur
l'arrêté de carence il y aura plutôt des
bons résultats et nous aurons aussi
également de bonnes actions d'urbanisme
dans ce sens aux chaînés la fusion
recueilli 30 et une voix pour et 2
contre l'opposition a critiqué le manque
de communication conseil municipal et
aurait préféré une autre orientation
stratégique pour la ville dont
considérons que la cette fusion arrive
bien tardivement
parce que la ville leur concours
beaucoup trop quitte désormais pour
fusionner avec le chesnay dans les
circonstances actuelles il faut
fusionner plus tôt avec une grande ville
en l'occurrence versailles pour arriver
une taille critique puissante pour poser
dans le grand paris prochaine étape la
présentation globale du projet le 8
octobre prochain le futur nom des
habitants n'est lui pas encore connue
pourrait être soumis à une consultation
sur internet
autre fusion dans les cartons mais
finalement abandonné le projet
concernant maurepas et coignard présenté
le 9 avril dernier
depuis cette annonce jean pierre
sauvestre maire sans étiquette de
coignières s'était mis en retrait de la
vie publique pour raisons de santé
il a repris ses fonctions en début de
semaine et nous a donné sa première
réaction suite à la bande à l'abandon du
projet de communes nouvelles avec
maurepas c'était ce mercredi dans le
journal c'est vrai c'est à distance que
j'ai vécu sept abandons de projets c'est
un projet qui dans un premier temps
devait lancer les études de fusion et de
création de communes nouvelles avec
maurepas c'était une première étape nous
avons voulu être transparents
effectivement et avant de faire les
études nous avons voulu effectivement un
conseil municipal d débattre des études
qui devait être fait pour trouver les
impacts qu'ils pouvaient être pour les
morlaisiens et pour les connais rien
mais je l' ai vécu d'une façon un peu
bien sûr j'étais déçu de l'abandon de ce
projet mais je considère que si les
connais rien effectivement ont donné un
avis plutôt négatif même pour lancer les
études ce que je regrette je me plie
bien sûr à la vie de la population
et justement cette fusion avortée a
laissé apparaître des tensions au sein
de la majorité des tensions cristallisé
ce mardi lors du conseil municipal à
coignières en raison d'une forte
affluence de la population et de la
salle trop petite celui ci a dû être
reporté une séance qui avait débuté sur
fond de polémique puisque le deuxième
adjoint en charge de la culture s'est vu
retirer ses délégations
aurélie rond et grégory canale
début de conseil municipal mouvementé à
coignières il ya quelques jours le maire
jean-pierre sevestre a saisi le
procureur de la république pour des
irrégularités et des manquements
réglementaire très grave au sein de son
équipe depuis trois ans je suis attelé à
remettre je dirais d'aplomb un petit peu
juridiquement et réglementairement la
maison car nous avions effectivement une
gestion auparavant qu'ils négligeaient
parfois la réglementation en ligne de
mire le précédent maire de la ville
henri pailleux et l'instituteur et
adjoint en charge de la culture ali
bousselham une délégation qui vient de
lui être retiré par arrêté jean-pierre
sevestre lui reprochent notamment
d'occuper un logement de 140 mètres
carrés sans payer de loyer depuis six
ans une situation que l'adjoint se
refuserait à régulariser pour les
enfants sont ainsi que j'estime que
c'est injuste de me déshonorer pour
quelque chose qui est qui et pas juste
qui n'est pas en tout cas qui n'est pas
lui qui n'est pas légal quoi en homme
d'honneur je proposerai as commis ce
geste de retirer cela s'il le retire
écoutez je me ravise ray je n'arrête pas
ester en justice parce que voilà c'est
ça qui est gênant pour des raisons de
sécurité l'assemblée vote le report du
conseil et une date ultérieure dans un
lieu plus grand alors que les
principales épreuves du baccalauréat se
termine ce vendredi en retour sur le
début de l'examen au programme de la
philosophie l'expérience peut-elle être
trompeuses
peut-on être insensible à l'art ou
encore le désir est il la marque de
notre imperfection les questions sur
lesquelles les candidats se sont penchés
sur pendant quatre heures
retour sur cette matinée au lycée emilie
de breteil de montigny le bretonneux
avec nicolas kirillovitch et patrick
jacques de dixmude
ce sont de vieilles habitudes répéter
tous les ans à seulement 15 minutes du
début de l'épreuve de philosophie les
temps de vérifier et distribuer les
copies selon les filets
hier les surveillants et enseignants
sont eux dispatchés dans les classes de
leur côté les élèves s'installent à 8
heures précises les épreuves écrites du
baccalauréat 2010 8 commence le lycée
tout entier passe alors en mode examen
je passais de salle en salle pour voir
si tout se passe bien faire voir les
professeurs s'il n'y a pas de problème
et essayer de rassurer tout le monde
puisque c'est aussi une épreuve même
pour les professeurs sont les leurs
élèves qui vont facile baccalauréat donc
elles sont aussi un peu stressée je
pense ça général ou technologique plus
de 300 candidats ont passé leur première
épreuve à montigny le bretonneux
après plus de trois heures de
concentration et d'efforts les premières
réactions ont été plutôt contrasté je
sais pas franchement je sais pas philo
c'est vraiment une matière où on peut
dire oui à pro finalement est donc là
versement donc voilà je me suis
débrouillé je pense assez bien je pense
j'ai réussi et on attend de voir la
suite
le deuxième sujet c'était sur la justice
et j'étais pas du tout à l'aise sur moi
je voulais la vérité ou le désir est là
juste la chance de tomber sur le désire
donc j'étais très contente
c'était pas trop difficile mais après je
pense pas avoir réussi tant que ça
réussit ou loupé les bacheliers n'ont
plus le temps de méditer sur la
philosophie demain matin place à à
l'histoire géographie
prenons maintenant la direction de la
verrière le site de la mgen est en
pleine restructuration
quatre pôles de spécialités médicales
sont en train de sortir de terre les
bâtiments accueilleront notamment des
secteurs pour la santé mentale des
adultes et des adolescents et un ehpad
les patients seront eux et bergers dans
les bâtiments et non plus d'un des
pavillons un reportage de mickaël
millero le chantier de la mgen de la
verrière avant ce jeudi 21 juin les
quatre pôles de spécialités médicales
qui comprendront notamment deux centres
de santé mentale et un ehpad commence à
prendre forme sur le site de 37 hectares
après un lancement des travaux à l'été
2016 tout une première partie de
terrassement un gros volume de
terrassement à évacuer
montage des grues en avril 2017 et on
est en train de terminer la phase gros
oeuvre des bâtiments on a déjà des
montées trois des cinq grues nous reste
deux grues en place et les corps d'état
techniques et architecturaux ont bien
démarré pour rénover la zone plusieurs
pavillons construits dans les années 60
ont été rasés les derniers bâtiments
rez-de-chaussée seront également détruit
dans les prochains mois et les patients
déplacer dans des structures
ultramodernes
une fois que le bat les bâtiments seront
réceptionnés les patients qui sont dans
les divers bat pavillon existants seront
transférés dans les nouveaux bâtiments
et nous viendrons détruire et finir les
espaces verts le but ultime étant que
les patients aient un lieu de vie j'irai
à caractère non pas hospitalier mais
plutôt un caractère
deux résidences normal au total
l'établissement 9 comprendra 5 104 lits
95 de plus qu'avant leur reconstruction
coût total de l'opération 80 millions
d'euros la livraison définitive est
prévue pour l'automne 2010 9 c'est la
fin de ce numéro du 7-8 ledo merci de
nous avoir suivis passé un excellent
week end
[Musique]